Morning again, Angie. Hey, Marky. Good morning.
Mhm.
Banaag.
Ohh.
Move.
Please don't mind my silence, I'm just going through the deck.
All good.
Hi, Candice. Good morning.
Hey, Candy. Good morning.
Good morning.
I got this.
How are you?
I am well. I apologize. I will be off camera this morning.
Bhattacharjee.
Everyone else should be joining here soon.
PH.
Both DJ and Matt, right?
Yes.
Gotcha. Okay.
So, how's everything, Candies?
I'm sorry.
How's everything?
I think things are good. I apologize. I have, I'm having some jaw issues right now and my face is kind of a little swollen. So I am, I may not be as tight as normal.
Mm.
No worries, no worries.
So I do apologize. Things are things are good. I know Angela is out today. I hope she she feels better.
Thank you. Thank you. You do take care of yourself, Candace. And while we are waiting, I believe we are connecting for the first time. So let me introduce myself. I'll be the CX. I'll be the customer representative for you, along with Andrea Marky. Think of me as a part of your extended team in case if there is
Thank you.
anything related to the services, anything at all, so feel free to reach out to me.
Hey, Lee, good morning.
Hello, everybody. Hi, Candace.
Hello.
Candice, I'm not sure if we've met. Have we met before? And forgive, I can't see your face, so I'm not sure.
I know, I apologize. I'm unfortunately off camera today. I believe we have met once, maybe once or twice over the time that we've all been working together.
No.
Brilliant. And no apology necessary. I totally get it. There are days where I will refuse to turn on my camera as well.
Ohh.
As usually, I can put, I can play spaces more than names if we, if we haven't interacted all that much, but it's a pleasure to see you again then, and appreciate you carving out the time.
Thank you.
We are just waiting for DJ.
Let me.
I mean, just reach out to them.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry, everyone.
It's okay.
No issues.
Looks like he might got her tied up.
It happens.
True.
Okay.
Is there, can we reschedule this? There is an on-site emergency and they're both heading. We have a client that is completely down.
Kour.
Sure.
TA.
Lee, you are muted if you are saying something.
You're on mutely.
Oh, I said we all understand that. So yes, of course.
Yeah, I apologize. Yeah, their entire VOP, VOIP system completely is out.
That happens.
That.
IP.
Gotcha. That's all right. You can probably message us, Candace, of the best time to reschedule it, and then we're going to resend the invite, especially to both DJ and Matt.
Eight.
Okay.
My shoes.
Yes.
Perfect. I know that DJ goes out of town the latter part of next week. So we may shoot for the last week of June or the first week of July.
Mhm.
Maybe the first or second. I'll get with them and look at their schedules and see what we can make work. And I'll send everything out. I do apologize all.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Art.
Probably.
I that that would work, yeah.
Okay, so we'll just do that. Just let me know which day of the first month of July would work, and then we'll be resending that invite. Okay.
Thank you.
All right, thank you very much. Get well soon, Canlas.
Thanks. Bye. Bye.
Great. Thanks, everybody.
Thank you, Candice. Thank you, everyone.
Yeah.